[تصفيق]
كيم جونج يكشف عوره امريكا والبيت الابيض
وبوليفيا تتعهد بالدفاع عن شعب القطاع مع
تجديد الهدنه وامل بتجديد اخر خروقات عده
في القطاع الجيش العبري يعترف من امريكا
ياتي الحل لحرب القطاع مدير السي اي اي
ورئيس المساد في قطر ما السبب النيران
الصادقه تسقط جنودا عبريين المجر مع روسيا
ضد الاتحاد الاوروبي تحذير روسي للقوات
الاوكرانيه وبوتين من دون روسيا القويه لا
يمكن تحقيق نظام عالمي دائم ومستقر وموسكو
تعلن عن مقاتله روسيه لم تحدث من قبل حل
وحيد اعتراف بايدن بفلسطين هو السبيل
لانهاء الحرب في غزه ه كذا اعلنت واشنطن
بوست الامريكيه بدوره قال الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين في رساله الى الرئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس ان مفتاح حل الصراع
بين الفصائل والقطاع هو اقامه دوله على
حدود عام 67 من جهتها تعهدت وزيره
الخارجيه البوليفيه الجديده سيلندا سوسا
خلال ادائها اليمين الدستوريه بمواصله
الدفاع عن القضيه الفلسطينيه ودعمها هناك
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان الولايات
المتحده لن تتوانى عن العمل حتى تحقيق حل
الدولتين في فرنسا رد رئيس الوزراء
الفرنسي السابق دومينيك دوفيلبان على
اتهامه بمعدات ساميه منددا بالتضييق على
كل من ينتقد تلابيب والتغيير الحاصل في
فرنسا بسبب ذلك مضيفا اصبحنا بلدا صغيرا
للغيه بسبب تلبيب بشان الهدنه افادت صحيفه
ديع تح رنو في وقت سابق بان امانه الحكومه
العبريه طلبت من الوزراء الموافقه على
زياده عدد اسماء الاسرى لديهم والمحتمل
الافراج عنهم من السجون من 50 الى 60
اسيرا فيما افادت صحيفه وول ستريت جورنال
نقلا عن مسؤولين مصريين وقطريين بان وقف
اطلاق النار طويل الامد في القطاع يتطلب
تقديم تنازلات يصعب قبولها لتنقل صحيفه
واشنطن بوست عن مصادر مطلعه قولها ان مدير
وكاله المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه سي اي
اي ويليام بيرنز ورئيس س ديفيد برنياع وصل
الى قطر لعقد اجتماعات بهدف التوصل الى
صفقه موسعه بين تلبيب والفصائل يجري ذلك
مع حديث عبري عن عشره ايام من التهدئه قبل
بحث الخيارات القادمه هذا وكان وزير
الدفاع الامريكي لوستن قد دعى نظيره
العبري اف جالنت الى العمل على السماح
بدخول المزيد من المساعدات الانسانيه الى
القطاع وقال مسؤولون امريكيون ان واشنطن
طالبت الابي بالامتناع عن تهجير المدن
من جنوبي القطاع حتى لو وسعت عمليتها هناك
لتجنب المزيد من النزوح وبينما تسري ايام
الهدنه اعلن المتحدث باسم الفصائل ان
القوات العبريه اخترقت الهدنه في شمال
القطاع ما اسفر عن اشتباكات بين الجانبين
واشار المتحدث الى ان مقاتلي الفصائل
تعاملوا مع الخرق العبري فيما افادت وسائل
اعلام باطلاق الدبابات العبريه النار شمال
غربي القطاع وتصاعد اعمده الدخان في
المنطقه بال الغم من تمديد الهدنه بدوره
كان الجيش العبري قد قال انه تم تفجير
ثلاث عبوات ناسفه بالقرب من قواته في
موقعين مختلفين شمال القطاع معتبرا انه
انتهاك للهدنه من طرف الفصائل واضاف الجيش
العبري ان ثمانيه من جنوده قتلوا في
القطاع خلال اسبوع واحد بنيران زملائهم
وحوادث تتعلق بالسلامه لتعلن صحيفه وي
ارتس ان الجيش العبري يقر باصابه 1 ضابط
وجندي منذ بدايه الحرب على القطاع بينهم
202 جروحهم خطه من جانب اخر كشف البنك
المركزي العبري ان الحرب على القطاع تكلف
الاقتصاد العبريه نحو
198 مليار شيكل اي 53 مليار دولار امريكي
لننتقل الى كوريا الشماليه حيث ذكرت وكاله
الانباء المركزيه هناك ان القمر الصناعي
الاستطلاعي الذي اطلقته بيون جانج الاسبوع
الماضي التقط صورا للبيت الابيض
والبنتاجون وقواعد عسكريه في الولايات
المتحده واشارت الوكاله الى ان زعيم
البلاد كيم جونجون قد اطلع على
الصور حليف جديد
لبوتين الانقسامات الاوروبيه تطفو على
السطح فمن يخفيها هنا يؤكد وزير الخارجيه
الهنجري بيتر سيارتو ان بلاده لن توافق
على عقوبات الاتحاد الاوروبي ضد قطاع
الطاقه الذريه الروسي مشيرا الى ان هذا
المقترح طرح خلال اجتماع وزاري للاتحاد من
جته اعلن الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان
الغرب يريدون تقطيع اوصال روسيا ونهبها ان
لم يكن بالقوه فمن خلال الاضطرابات واوضح
بوتين ان موسكو ستعتبر اي تدخل خارجي في
شؤون روسيا الداخليه او استفزاز عملا
عدوانيا ضد روسيا وسيتم الرد عليه بحزمه
مضيفا انه من دون روسيا القويه ذات
السياده لا يمكن تحقيق نظام عالمي دائم
ومستقر فيما اكد متحدث الكرملين ديمتري ان
حلف النيتو يرى في روسيا خصمه ويضحي
بالشعب الاوكراني لاحتوائها وموسكو تدرك
ذلك وتواصل عمليتها العسكريه في اوكرانيا
وبشان اوكرانيا وصف رئيس مجلس النواب
الامريكي مارك جونسون مساعده كيف بانها
اولويه بالنسبه للمشرعين الامريكيين لكنه
شدد على ضروره تخصيص اموال اضافيه لسياسه
الحدود الامريكيه في اخبار المعارك حذر
قائد قوات الوقايه الاشعاعيه والكيميائيه
البيولوجي ايجور كيريلوف من ان تلجا
القوات الاوكرانيه الى استخدام اسلحه
بيولوجيه بسبب فشل هجومها المضاد فيما
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تكبيد الجيش
الاوكراني اكثر من
385 قتيلا وجريحا وتحرير مواقع متقدمه في
محيط مدينه ارتيم فيسك الاستراتيجيه على
محور الدونتس خلال 24 ساعه وبين هذا وذاك
فادت صحيفه امريكيه مختصه بالشؤون
العسكريه بان المقاتل الروسيه سو 57 التي
تحمل على متنها طائره صغيره دون طيار
ستصبح طائره مقاتله فريده من نوعها في
العالم ولم تحدث من قبل من شانه ان يزيد
بشكل كبير من فعاليتها في القتال الجوي
وسوف يحسن
[موسيقى]
الدفاع
h